sous les assauts incessants des forces
pro russes lusine à l'aube ce talent
dernière poche de résistance ukrainienne
à marioupol depuis des jours des
combattants ukrainien ils sont
retranchés mais aussi un millier de
civils selon les autorités municipales
à court de vivres les soldats segi ont
lancé mercredi un appel à l'aide
désespéré sur les réseaux sociaux
nous vivons peut-être nos derniers jours
voir nos dernières heures l'ennemi est
dix fois plus nombreux que nous
nous appelons et supplions tous les
dirigeants du monde de nous aider nous
leur demandons d'utiliser la procédure
d'extraction et de nous emmener sur le
territoire d'un pays tiers
le président ukrainien affirme que sa
demande d'évacuation auprès de la russie
est restée lettre morte
malheureusement nous n'avons pas eu de
réponse de la russie à l'offre d'échangé
pourrait sauver les civils et les
défenseurs de marioupol
ce silence notez par tous ceux qui ont
été ou peuvent être associés à la russie
ces dernières heures la russie a
intensifié ses attaques sur tout le
front est dans son viseur des villes
comme sauvian sq ou encore cramatte orsc
dans cette ville quasi déserte et les
habitants qui restent sont résignés
je le prends calmement ce qui doit
arriver arrivera
ck je ne vais pas m'enfuir n'importe où
avec cette offensive
la russie affirme être entré dans une
nouvelle phase de la guerre
son objectif prendre le dombass
l'armée russe exécutent les tâches
fixées par le chef des armées pour
l'opération militaire spéciale en
conséquence le plan de libération des
républiques populaires de tonia kehl où
on skie mise en oeuvre ainsi que des
mesures pour restaurer la paix mais on
agit en parallèle la russie poursuit ses
assauts sur les autres villes assiégées
à kharkiv au moins quatre personnes ont
été tuées mardi dans des bombardements
sur des quartiers résidentiels